Speaker 1: one of the things that is
unfortunately missing right now in the
sort of national discussion around almost every
issue in media, but in particular around some of
the COVID disinformation is just like simple
gut check questions. What do I mean by that?
What am I talking about? Well, all the talk about
religious exemptions to the COVID vaccine? Well,
some states allow religious exemptions. Some
don't. Some organizations allow religious
exemptions. Some don't. A basic question that
you would think is like the first question you
would ever ask when someone says I objected on
religious grounds to the vaccine would be, Oh,
what is your religion? What is the objection
and what other vaccines does it apply to?
Right? When someone says, Well, I, my religion
is in conflict with the COVID vaccine. Oh, OK,
well, where does it say that? And does it also
object to the MMR vaccine? Does it also object
to the Hep B vaccine? What is the objection?
Tucker Carlson yesterday hosted fighter pilot Lt.
Col. Scott Duncan, who explains, I am battling
the military for a religious exemption
from having to get the COVID vaccine. All right,
well, let's take a listen to what he had to say
and keep those questions I mentioned in mind.
Speaker 3: Well, here's one of the sadder stories
which we did more of the Scott Duncan is
a fighter pilot. He's Lieutenant Colonel,
United States Marine Corps. He has filed a
religious exemption to the military's vaccine
mandate. Has not been approved. Right now, it's
on appeal. So far, the US military's issued just
two religious exemptions total. If Mr Duncan's
appeal does not succeed, he will be discharged
to the military. Walter will likely use hundreds
of experienced pilots due to this mandate. Lt.
Col. Scott Duncan joins us tonight from thanks so
much for coming on, and I think of the experienced
pilots that the US military, the Marine Corps,
this country stands to lose. You've got to be,
you know, in the top quartile for experience
that you've flown over 300 combat missions,
over 200 carrier landings. You
know, you've got to kind of wonder
who the military is prioritizing a vaccine
over that kind of experience defending the
country. But. What's your conclusion? Well, thank
you, sir. Thank you, sir, for the opportunity
to join you tonight. Target is specifically to
be able to convey our personal experiences and
just understand it as an active duty service
member to these views are not held by the United
States Marine Corps, the Department of Defense.
But we do believe that yes, we have a reasonable
argument. We've asked our leadership immediately
as well as our congressional leadership to inquire
as to really the cost-benefit analysis of
losing several hundred very qualified aviators.
The average time and grade for those
aviators is 14 years, and also to just
consider the second and third order effects
and consequences of what they have to offer.
I'm not unique in my situation. There
are many incredibly qualified individuals
with a tremendous amount of experience, and
we believe that that could be a detriment
to national defense in the event we separate that
many aviators. Yeah, I mean, you could make a lot
more flying corporate or for the airlines than
you're making now, you and all the rest of these
guys. So you've got to think you're doing this for
a reason, a noble reason. Let me ask you about the
grounds of the exemption that you're requesting.
It's a religious exemption. Yes, sir. Well, how
would you characterize your the problems
that you have with the vaccine? One of the
problems we had personally with the vaccine, and
we understand there's a reasonable disagreements.
We do disagree with the pedigree and the
technology maturation over time. That's one issue.
The other is just a conviction by the Holy Spirit,
and I believe we are led in that fashion and we do
not have any piece about the vaccine itself.
Speaker 1: So, so think about that, he says.
The technology pedigree and the way. So what?
He said there is complete mush, mouth mush,
mouth nonsense. But it could also apply to a
whole bunch of other vaccines that he clearly
accepted because he's in the military and the
military is one of the most vaccinated groups
of people in the United States. Adam Kinzinger,
the Republican congressman, tweeted about this
and he said, I'm having a hard time squaring how
you can be religiously opposed to a COVID vaccine,
but took the anthrax, smallpox, flu, typhoid,
yellow fever, MMR, etc. to join and remain in
and that not have violated your
religion. This is a very important point.
We have to be able to say. Lieutenant Colonel,
what you just said doesn't make any sense. First,
where in your religious texts does it say that
this vaccine is not OK? And how would it not apply
to the list of vaccines everybody in
the military gets at basic training
adenovirus? We have the list up on the screen from
Newsweek. Have a happy flu, MMR, meningococcal
polio virus, tetanus, diphtheria, varicella and
then depending on your particular occupation.
Anthrax, Haemophilus influenzae type b Japanese
encephalitis. Pneumococcal rabies. Small. OK,
I could go on explain exactly what
this means because the truth is,
and I'm not being facetious here, if there
is a real basis here and I know that by real,
we're talking about religious texts which are
only relevant to those who follow that religion.
Why would an atheist or a Buddhist consider
what the Catholic religious texts say they
wouldn't. And I understand that that
this is all self-professed stuff. But
if you're going to professor, at least show
me where the texts say. It's a no on COVID,
but it's a yes on these 10 other vaccines. It's
not being asked. And even Tucker, when he says,
explain to me the genesis of this objection. He
says, Well, it's the pedigree and the technology.
And dude, that doesn't mean anything. And we
should be able to say, and I know that these are
considered it's considered offensive sometimes to
ask these questions because it's their religion.
But if they are asserting imposing religion onto
a civil system, then it should be allowed to ask
obvious questions like, All right, explain it to
me where? Where, what's the passage? Or Give me
some some verse or explain, explain it to me so
that then I can understand what it is that you're
saying. And of course, it doesn't make any sense.
This guy's got 10 15 vaccines, clearly because
he's been in the military. But this one violates
his religion. We shouldn't allow it just because
someone says it's my religion, we should actually
get the information. If you disagree with me,
let me know. You can find me on Twitter at
Packman. We're going to take a very quick break
and be right back. The David Pakman show is
funded primarily by listeners of the podcast,
viewers on YouTube, people who listen to the
show on the radio or watch on free speech TV
who sign up for memberships on my website. That
website is Join Packman Gqom. It's cheap, it's
quick. It directly goes to support our Daily Show
and also gets you a ton of great perks, including
the Daily Bonus Show, commercial free audio and
video feeds of the show, which are made available
six hours earlier for our members. No waiting
until the clips get published or the podcast
goes out. You get the show very, very early in
the day. You can sign up at join Packman dot com.